malgré un accord de paix signé en mai
dernier le darfour replonge dans la
guerre civile des centaines de milliers
de réfugiés sont privés des
d'alimentaire et vivent dans
l'insécurité la plus totale
aujourd'hui les ong en appelle à
l'intervention des nations unies
christophe nardini voici guéret ida le
plus grand camp de réfugiés au monde
ici vivent des dizaines de milliers de
personnes
ou plutôt survivent dans des tentes à
même le sol avec le strict nécessaire
seul salut pour ces familles l'aide
humanitaire internationale
sans cette distribution régulière de
vivre aucune chance de s'en sortir
ici dans le sud du darfour nous essayons
de nourrir plus de cent trente mille
personnes
ceux qui sont là ont fui les combats
pour se regrouper massivement ces
derniers mois le pays a pourtant
officiellement signé un accord de paix
en mai dernier un accord ratifié par un
seul groupe rebelle tous les autres
refusent toujours la paix résultat le
darfour est en proie à des règlements de
comptes interethniques pire
l'armée soudanaise aurait bombardé ces
derniers jours des villages entiers
abritant de soi disant terroristes à
demi-mot le secrétaire général des
nations unies parlent de génocide nous
pouvons nous en conscience laisser le
peuple du darfour un tel destin qui a
fait la communauté internationale
après n'avoir pas fait assez pour le
peuple du rwanda quand il en avait
besoin
peut-elle se contenter d'observer alors
que la tragédie s'intensifient à cette
traque des dépouilles
il n'est plus temps le thème de s'en
tenir aux demi-mesures d'un mètre ou de
repousser les débats au frappe mais
celle de bates face à de telles
exactions le conseil de sécurité a voté
la résolution 17 06 elle prévoit
d'envoyer vingt mille casques bleus pour
protéger la population pour le soudan
une ingérence inacceptable c'est doris
mais en adoptant la résolution 17 06 le
conseil de sécurité a délibérément pris
des mesures hâtives sans discuter du
contexte politique avec les différentes
parties impliquées
pas même avec le gouvernement soudanais
depuis le conflit est entré dans une
nouvelle spirale de violence
à tel point que les ong envisage de
quitter le pays et ce malgré la détresse
et la famine qui menace photographe ces
trois derniers mois nous avons été
incapables de venir en aide à quelques
350 m refuge incapable d'envoyer nos
équipes sur place
tout cela à cause de la violence qui
règne douze des nôtres ont été tués de
limay une insécurité qui rappelle celle
des premières heures du conflit en
février 2003 cette guerre civile n'en
finit pas de durer avec déjà trois cent
mille morts et un tiers de la population
déplacée